okay so we have the episode the desert
and we got this is a one where pretty
much they lose Appa in the last one I
was playing it up else my god no but
it's like holy this is like a
really big deal
make it like this huge huge ordeal in
this episode and again if feels
justified it feels justified that there
should be a big deal because even Katara
and Sokka and everyone else he's come
across egg has probably had the longest
connection to anything alive with Appa
and it's the only friend he has that
doesn't talk back that doesn't question
him he's just sort of always on his side
and will always go along with wherever
he wants to go and we'll take him there
and I think anyone that's had a pet can
really relate to losing that pet and
feeling responsible for losing him um so
you go for him being unbelievably angry
and vengeful through this by think sort
of unlike some of the other times where
they did it again it feels like this is
really warranted because this is someone
that he's been very close to even if it
is an animal in fact in a strange way it
makes more sense if it's an animal
because I don't think he's ever dealt
with he's dealt with loss of people and
it's really hurt him this is the first
time he's lost a creature that was
really close to it you know uh
essentially a pet in a sense you know
it's like a cowboy losing his horse or
something it's a big deal and I like
that he isn't just angry and that's it
it's a it really carries through the
whole entire episode to a point where it
really sort of it pushes his patience
big time and he has another avatar state
freakout near the end but it's it's
brief and I like I like being with
Katara sort of bringing him out but she
doesn't even have to say anything
and I like her not freaking out when she
sees him starting to really go nuts I
like that and I won't say she knows that
she has the answer but
she understands what he's going through
and I think because of that she most
likely has the right idea of how to snap
him out of it and I think that's why she
looks so calm there and also so very sad
because she does know what he's going
through because this is a very different
kind of loss for him but again they seem
to have sort of this connection this
kinship uh so that's one story going on
they have which they do very well I
think the capture the frustration of the
surge the frustration of being lost the
frustration of having something that you
kind of took for granted is since gone
you know it's like I don't know it's
like us being in the middle over without
our car or something it's like we forgot
how much we really need that car or
electron electricity or any of that
stuff you know what's something that you
rely so much on is gone and I feel they
really capture that while also
connecting it to a living being which
makes it even worse so they can't find
frustration very well um you also have
an hour story with again we with Zuko in
the uncle uh the Lotus piece actually
Serna ties it I mean not that one piece
but the Lotus game actually Serta ties
in which I thought was really cool
apparently the uncle is part of like
this secret underground Brotherhood that
is still kind of kept in secret by the
end of it all but it's still pretty cool
I know is this or like a Freemason thing
going on here and I like that it's so
secret that even Zuko is not allowed
into it they have to keep him out they
have to close the door I thought that
that was pretty funny when he has to
actually when the uncle I start talking
through the little slit in the door and
I love that um ah I think what else I
mean mostly it was just it was capturing
Aang's frustration and again it an
episode that just wants to take time
showing the frustration showing the
anger yeah it again it just feels like
it really belonged here and it was the
right amount of time to devote to it and
even then it doesn't end
on Oh we'll find him Oh golly gee I mean
it ends on this very sad image of her
holding a and you know and him crying
you know pretty much sobbing in her arms
is I mean it it's not a happy image and
you know at the beginning of the episode
you find that oppas lost and by the end
of the episode op is still lost we
haven't really gotten that far and
sometimes I think in something that's
trying to show this journey is trying to
show the many variations of the journey
and the elements of the journey and
different things that come along the way
and emotionally what I can do to you I
think it's good just to have a moment
where it sinks in hey this you know
someone you love might really be gone
you know not dead necessarily just gone
you can't get to him and you don't know
exactly where are what's being done or
any of that and it's a hard thing to
deal with and I like that here's an
episode that's just sort of dealing with
a certain stage of grief um you know
instead of going through all the stages
as a lot of episodes do for ya for a lot
of shows particularly kid shows at the
LA live-action shows do that too so I
like that we only see like one stage of
grief I'm sort of hoping they go more
into it in a sense I hope it's not like
this is it and then the next episode
he's like oh well whatever and it's just
a non-issue he's gonna go make jokes
again or something like I mean I really
hope it still carries over into the next
one because I felt like they've really
established this is just one part of
grief if they do in the next one where
he's just like he's fine
unless he's like trying to hide it or
protect it or something like that I'm
gonna be really pissed off um you know
but if if they go that route and again
acknowledged that he's trying to hold it
in or something and just try to hide it
with humor isn't bammy that's fine but
if they just really go the route like
okay let's just go on with our adventure
maybe we'll find out hopefully I'll be
really annoyed if that's the case so um
yeah just a pretty good strong episode
tov really seems to be sort of
establishing a good character here too I
haven't talked I haven't talked too much
about her I probably should more I think
they're giving her much more of a
personality in this and it is a distinct
personality and it's it's sort of this
it's this tough girl but not she's a
touch bratty which I kind of like and
she's a little bit she's like this tiny
little thing but she's a bit of a thug -
but she's also very smart and needs to
be knows that she needs to be strong has
been pampered all her life and I I like
this I like this character on board so
um yeah just another really good episode
and I'll see you in the next one